thanks to brilliant for sponsoring this
video stick around to the end to find
out how you can learn about maths
science and computer science in a fun
interactive way
over the past 2 000 years our planet's
population has increased from around 230
million people to nearly 8 000 million
people slowly at first and then
incredibly quickly in the past few
centuries at the same time the
concentration of carbon dioxide in our
planet's atmosphere is increased from
around 280 parts per million to around
420 parts per million slowly at first
and then incredibly quickly in the past
few centuries wait a minute the more
people there are the more energy gets
used and historically that energy has
been provided by the burning of fossil
fuels which puts carbon dioxide into our
atmosphere however the more people there
are the more food we need to grow and
food ultimately comes from the process
of photosynthesis plants turning water
carbon dioxide and sunlight into sugars
and oxygen so more co2 should mean more
food right as ex-representative lamar
smith a republican who chaired the house
committee on science from 2013 to 2019
put it a higher concentration of carbon
dioxide in our atmosphere would aid
photosynthesis which in turn contributes
to increased plant growth this
correlates to a greater volume of food
production and better quality food
amazing
every word of what you just said
was wrong i'm not endorsing the last
jedi by the way i think it's terrible
let me know your review in the comments
below
the science is very clear that more co2
in the atmosphere means less food being
grown the intergovernmental panel on
climate change stated with high
confidence in the most recent working
group 2 report that climate change will
increasingly put pressure on food
production and access especially in
vulnerable regions undermining food
security and nutrition and there are two
crises bound up in that statement the
first is the amount of food we can grow
a planet with more co2 in its atmosphere
is a warmer planet and as a rule of
thumb for cereal crops such as corn
wheat and rice currently grown in
optimal conditions each degree of
warming results in a 10
decrease in yield crops don't like being
hotter than they're used to now you
might think that as the planet warms the
places where we could grow food will
extend towards the poles and so we could
just move where the farms are and to be
partially right the world's natural
wheat belt for example the locations
where conditions are right to grow wheat
has been moving towards the poles at a
rate of about 160 miles or 250
kilometers each decade but the problem
is not all soils are created equally and
the locations that the wheatbelt was
moving into in canada and russia
specifically have soils that are much
less fertile than where wheat is
currently grown and those areas are less
serviced by infrastructure studies
estimate that wheat specifically might
still actually increase in overall yield
for a few decades as we warm but the
total yield of grains in particular rice
maize and soybeans will fall
it don't it don't go down probably it
goes down
no it don't go down oh
additionally a planet with more co2 in
its atmosphere a warmer planet is a
planet with different patterns of
rainfall and we've already seen the
droughts have become more common thanks
to climate change and while it's very
difficult to model scientists are pretty
confident that in the future droughts
will be even more common and even more
intense and that will negatively affect
agricultural output even further and the
warmer the planet gets the worse the
droughts become as david wallace wells
writes in the uninhabitable earth these
droughts will be the real problem for
agriculture at two degrees of warming
droughts will wallop the mediterranean
and much of india and corn and sorghum
all around the world will suffer
straining global food supply at 2.5
degrees thanks mostly to drought the
world could enter a global food deficit
needing more calories than the planet
can produce by 2080 without dramatic
reductions in emissions southern europe
will be in a permanent extreme drought
much worse than the american dust bowl
ever was for what it's worth at that
point the american southwest and plains
will be in a drought worse than anything
we've seen in the past thousand years
and bread basket regions of china south
america the middle east and africa will
no longer be viable as reliable sources
of food this is bad enough there is no
way we're going to be able to grow
enough food for a still-growing
population on a warmer planet with more
droughts
there will be widespread famines this
century
nothing to soften that one that's that's
just a fact but
there is a second crisis bound up in
that statement from the ipcc that i
mentioned earlier and it's
not really talked about at all
yet is going to cause cascading problems
the second crisis is
nutrition in 2004 a paper was published
in the journal of the american college
of nutrition by davis epp and riordan
the paper found that the nutrient
content of various crops potatoes
carrots okra cabbages among others had
decreased over the past several decades
food grown in the 1990s had less protein
calcium iron and vitamin c than that
grown in the 50s and by quite some
margin 15 to 20 decreases on average and
a nearly 40 percent decrease in vitamin
b2 the authors concluded that this was
due to modern farmers and gardeners
choosing different varieties of crops
that were faster growing but less
nutrient dense
however mathematician iraqi laladzi
along with a few other scientists didn't
buy this he hypothesized that as more
and more carbon dioxide was present in
the atmosphere plants generally were
undergoing an increasing imbalance in
their elemental composition containing
more carbon from sugars produced by more
photosynthesis and fewer other molecules
like vitamins that are produced using
elements from the soil like iron and
zinc
in other words the plants were becoming
less nutritious and more like
junk food summarizing in a politico
article titled the great nutrient
collapse lalanzi says every leaf and
every grass blade on earth makes more
and more sugars as co2 levels keep
rising we are witnessing the greatest
injection of carbohydrates into the
biosphere in human history an injection
that dilutes other nutrients in our food
supply and this hypothesis was confirmed
by further studies a nature paper in
2014 concluded that grains and legumes
grown in elevated co2 concentrations
possessed significantly less zinc and
iron a 2018 paper looked at the protein
content of 18 strains of rice and found
that more co2 in the air produced
decreases in protein but also iron zinc
and various vitamins in the rice just to
restate that
rice what you're doing drain the oh my
god a crop relied upon by hundreds of
millions if not billions of people who
in the future will be increasingly
deficient in vitamins and minerals that
are fundamental to healthy biological
function proteins necessary to grow and
repair muscle and bone a lack of iron
causes fatigue a zinc deficiency weakens
the immune system in a sense this is
nothing new it's estimated that today
approximately 2 billion people suffer
from deficiencies in iron and zinc alone
causing a loss of 63 million life years
annually in other words people are
sicker and are dying younger now because
of these deficiencies and those
deficiencies are only going to get worse
on a planet with more co2 in its
atmosphere that might not sound as big a
deal as there not being enough food
full stop to go around
but think about what the knock-on
effects are gonna be a population that
is deficient in various micronutrients
is a population that will be physically
weaker more likely to get sick less able
to recover from being sick or being
injured and will suffer more problems in
pregnancy
in other words a population that will be
able to work less and will put
increasing pressure on health care
systems furthermore those at greatest
risk of these deficiencies are in the
global south where there's less
healthcare provision and higher rates of
disease and so where the effects will be
felt most keenly an epidemic of
micronutrient deficiencies will
significantly invisibly amplify the
other effects of climate change such as
shifting patterns of disease and the
response to extreme weather events like
droughts
millions of people will die early
because of this and if that wasn't bad
enough it's going to specifically apply
the most pressure to those parts of the
world already hardest hit by climate
change as we so frequently find the
societal impacts of this crisis are
interlinked with one factor amplifying
others that means however that any
actions we take now to limit the
emissions of greenhouse gases will help
fix this problem
the more action we take now the more
this problem is fixed this provides a
roadmap for us in order to avoid
widespread famines and an epidemic of
micronutrient deficiencies that will
cause cascading problems in global
health we need to do everything we can
to bring emissions of greenhouse gases
down to net zero
as soon as possible it's that simple
and you know also has a couple of other
benefits
finally it's a good thing iraqi laladzi
was a mathematician and performed his
analysis of declining nutrition of
foodstuffs using skills developed over
his degrees in mathematics statistical
skills in particular allow you to look
at the world differently and do things
that other people simply can't
but you don't have to dedicate yourself
to degrees in mathematics in order to
learn these skills you can start
developing them yourself using brilliant
who have kindly sponsored this video
brilliant is a website and app that
improves your skills in maths science
and computer science by introducing you
to new ideas and immediately getting you
to apply them they offer interactive
expertly written courses from middle
school level to graduate school level
across subjects as diverse as statistics
cryptocurrency chemistry and astronomy
crucially brilliant emphasizes that the
objective here is just to try not
necessarily to be correct after all if
you answer a question incorrectly
what's the worst that happens you just
learn from the experience and you
improve the next time if you're in
full-time education brilliant offers an
alternative resource to the classroom
shedding light on subjects from a
different angle well if you're in the
big scary adult world brilliant offers
an opportunity to develop your
scientific thinking and problem-solving
skills and introduces you to subjects
that you've always been a bit curious
about to get started for free visit
brilliant.org simon clark or click the
link in the description and the first
200 people to do so will get 20 off
brilliant's annual premium subscription
for themselves or a student in their
lives thanks to brilliant for sponsoring
this video and for being well
brilliant
thank you so much for watching this
video if you found this subject
interesting then i'd highly recommend
reading the uninhabitable earth by david
wallace wells i'll leave a link to that
in the description next to that will
also be a link to the politico article i
mentioned the great nutrient collapse
which is really eye-opening reading i'd
recommend having a look at that too if
you're looking for a video
recommendation then here's two from me
over here you can also subscribe to the
channel down here if you're not already
and you can sign up to brilliant if you
enjoyed the video if enjoys the right
word please do pop it like and tell
people about it you think they find it
interesting that just leaves me to say
thank you so much for watching i'll see
you in the next one